I have the new Omen transcend 16. and so
do you I absolutely am obsessed with
this laptop especially like the color
scheme of it too like it's just so
beautiful it's so fast and today we are
going to play genjen impact we're gonna
play gunshin impact so I just started
playing this game it's very fun and
already addicting which is scary for our
personalities I know these types of open
world games I will go down and just be
playing for hours and hours on end it's
also running very well I was playing
this in bed last night and I was having
so much I just like forgot how fun it is
to play video games because you've been
so busy and I just feel like the laptop
life being able to just walk around my
house with my game 100 since like we've
been traveling a lot more this year yeah
being able to just take this with me as
my dedicated gaming device has been just
amazing